actually i really want to talk to you
about get real with diabetes um because
we touched on that with mama the last
time you were here
but you're doing a campaign this is
personal for you
you're bike riding around the city
there's this whole lifestyle going on
and i want in on the information well uh
i was diagnosed with type 2 diabetes 21
years ago uh i was the first person in
my family uh to be diagnosed with it
then my mom and then we found out that
my dad had been living with diabetes
undiagnosed for over 20 years
and uh subsequently lost my father to
complications of diabetes so that's why
i partnered with novo nordisk five years
ago uh to talk about this and uh you
know little known fact i didn't know
this that cardiovascular disease heart
attacks and strokes
i'm four times at greater risk to get it
uh to die from those things than you are
because i'm a type 2 diabetic and those
are things that we need to address
within the community and so we have a
campaign called get real about diabetes
and our website is get real about
diabetes.com and you can go there and
get the information that you need
to learn how to prevent the disease and
if you are diagnosed with it how to live
with it uh and it doesn't have to be a
death sentence and and that's that's
what we're here to talk about that's
what we're here you know to give
information to the community uh and so
that they can spread that information
within their families and within their
communities so we could help you know
hopefully one day eradicate this i think
you are i know that you will now
is it true that you
ride your bike all over the city i i do
i do
uh i ride my bike i bought a bike ten
years ago when it went 12 years ago when
i was living here i bought a bike and
just started i ride the train you know
this is how you get around i walk the
streets i ride the train and i ride my
bike
and that's what you do when you live in
new york and so i'm i'm i'm i i'm an
unofficial new yorker
well i love that you're here in this
country because i love being here i'm
now a new yorker and i'm so proud
although i would not attempt getting on
a bike because i just know i would be
road pizza in one block
one block anthony maybe you can give me
less i can imagine i will i will we'll
get a bike and we can go this is what
we'll do we'll ride in central park
together we'll just be easy we'll start
easy first we're right in the park
okay we're riding the park we're getting
a little bike path we're riding the park
will you i'm serious i'm serious we can
do that i think we can do that that's
that's a date all right you got it thank
you
it's like every day i walk by the city
bikes and the internal dialogue is
you're a big wuss
you should melt that thing and be bald
and ride
oh
that's one way of looking at it
all right well maybe mount it
just mount the bike drew that's right
stop being a wuss melt that sucker and
ride
[Music]
um okay now
you're the host of to tell the truth yes
and you already have your hot hands in
so many honey pots i do i do you know i
saw an opportunity to uh give my mother
an opportunity to live out her dream and
uh this is she always wanted to be an
actress and it never happened for her
because she's horrible but um
no so she's she's my my co-host on the
show and we're going into seven seasons
now so
yeah
thanks to you guys and what more fun
than to like do this with your loved
ones
[Music]